we now have less than a month before
Apple announces their upcoming 2019
iPhone 11 lineup and there have been
many many leaks and rumors spreading
around but one thing that seems to be
for sure is that the notch at the top of
the display is sticking around for
another year meanwhile Samsung and other
smart phone companies have already dealt
with the knotch and offer much cleaner
looking solutions for the front-facing
camera the 2019 iPhones are gonna need
something really special to convince
people to upgrade instead of sticking
with their current and still very
powerful iPhones we here at Mac's sec
are gonna buy them regardless since we
want to make comparison videos to other
smartphones like the oneplus 7 pro and
Galaxy Note 10 to the subscribe right
now so you don't miss out but the main
question we have is this what's it gonna
take for people to upgrade so let's talk
about a few things that we would
personally like to see in the upcoming
iPhone 11 line up multiple recent rumors
have been pointing to there being three
models of the iPhone 11 replacing the
10s 10s Macs and 10 are but the most
interesting rumor is that one or two of
the models will actually be named the
iPhone 11 Pro possibly in both a small
and large size now this is interesting
because Apple has never named an iPhone
with the pro branding that's been
reserved for mostly Mac computers and in
the last few years the iPad pro so if
there will be an iPhone 11 Pro we can
only guess that there will be some
serious upgrades that make it stand out
from older iPhones so let's run through
everything we think that pro badge could
bring starting with the camera one thing
that's almost been confirmed is that at
least one of the three models will come
with a triple lense camera many renders
of a square camera bump have hit the
internet in so far I'm not impressed I
personally like the look of the
traditional vertically oriented bump
compared to this odd-looking square
camera but then I had this thought what
if the features that come with this
camera are so compelling that people
simply won't care if it looks a bit
worse they'll buy it because it's that
much better
we'll probably see a huge improvement to
image and video quality especially for
nighttime photos and maybe even a new
portrait video mode just like on the
galaxy note 10
which will use the ultra wide lens to
capture more of the photo allowing you
to fix the framing of your shot without
having a crop in but one thing that I'm
hope
for the Apple hasn't yet done before is
the option of shooting photos in RAW of
course you can find third party apps for
that on the App Store but if Apple
chooses to add raw it's going to work
incredibly well now here's something
that'll be a complete game changer if it
happens the addition of the Pearl
branding on the iPhone might mean that
it's getting promotion technology just
like on every iPad pro for the last
couple of years
promotion basically means that the
screen will have a 120 Hertz refresh
rate just like the asus rog phone - but
pro motion does it better instead of
being stuck at 120 Hertz or 90 Hertz
like on the oneplus 7 pro pro motion can
actually dynamically lower the refresh
rate down to a minimum of 24 Hertz if
you're watching 24 FPS content like
movies and macs tech videos this means
that you get the best of both worlds all
the time high refresh rate when you need
it in much better battery life when you
don't so if the iPhone 11 pro will get
promotion technology it can push massive
amounts of people to upgrade and here's
another possibility the pro models could
come with the USBC connector instead of
lightning now I know most rumors point
to lightning connectors
but what if the iPhone will take after
the iPad pro which is the only iPads to
come with USB see compared to the rest
of the iPad lineup that has stuck with
lightning first off we're already
expecting the iPhone 11 to ship with the
new USBC 18 watt power adapter which is
by the way perfect for fast charging
recent iPhones and some leaks even show
a USBC connector when asked to plug into
a macbook so there may be a small chance
we'll see USB see on just the iPhone 11
Pro models and the cheaper Lightning
models will come with the USB C to
lightning cable for use with a new 18
watt power brick a USB C port is exactly
what the iPhone 11 pro needs to convince
more people to upgrade and since air
pods - recently came out with a wireless
charging case we're expecting the iPhone
11 to feature reverse wireless charging
as well and finally let's talk about the
expected a 13 chip that will be powering
the iPhone 11 some leaks and rumors are
pointing to a much larger battery than
the iPhone 10 s models which could mean
that the a 13 chip is going to be a lot
more powerful especially in terms of
graphics performance so those are just a
few things
personally think will help the iPhone
11pro be a game-changer and make
consumers upgrade their iPhones even
despite having that same old notch
sticking around for another year if you
disagree with me or if you know of any
other leaks or rumors comment down below
if you enjoy the video tap like and
click the circle above to subscribe
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]